billions of americans are wondering how
they will be paying their bills with
expanded unemployment benefits set to
run out
next week lawmakers left washington on
friday before finalizing a deal to renew
that economic lifeline
after the coronavirus pandemic forced so
many americans out of work
paula reed is traveling with the
president who is spending the weekend
at his new jersey golf club and she
joins us now paula good morning
good morning dana the president is here
in new jersey as the white house and
republicans
struggle to finalize their proposal for
this next relief bill
republicans say they want to scale back
some of these jobless benefits
but they can't agree on exactly how to
do that
leaving tens of millions of americans in
limbo
president trump did not stop to talk to
reporters as he arrived in new jersey
friday night
while washington is gripped in a
contentious battle over
unemployment benefits president trump
tweeted about alleged spying on his 2016
campaign
right before stepping off the plane in
an interview with bar stool sports
thursday
president trump made a rare admission of
remorse
revealing that he often regrets his
tweets
we put it out instantaneously we feel
great
and then you start getting phone calls
did you really say this he also lamented
how kovitt has impacted his chances of
reelection
we were sailing george washington would
have had a hard time beating us
and then when the china virus came in
all of a sudden you know it's a dampener
with just over a hundred days until the
election
30 million americans remain unemployed
in the wake of covid
the federal jobless benefits congress
approved in april
600 dollars per person per week are
about to expire
house democrats passed a bill two months
ago to extend the 600 dollar payments
through
january but senate republicans say they
will introduce their plan on monday
in my view it ought to be very much
front loaded
toward immediate help immediate help
but negotiations could take weeks and on
friday
the senate floor was empty republicans
are derelict in their duty
taking off for the weekend instead of
being ready all these months
without preparing something to begin
with the president was banking on an
economic recovery to propel him to
reelection
but newly appointed trump campaign
manager bill stephen
insists national polls which
consistently show
biden leading understate the president's
support
most national polls continue to show the
president trailing joe biden when it
comes to seniors
and yesterday the president signed
several measures aimed at reducing drug
prices
a short time ago the president tweeted
about those measures and reminded
seniors to quote
remember your favorite president later
today here in new jersey the president
will meet with supporters
dana all right paula thank you